so I still program quite a bit in PHP
and I'm sure there's other languages
like this but the dollar sign before a
variable
that was always an annoying thing for me
it didn't quite fit into my
understanding of why this is good for a
programming language I'm not sure if you
ever thought about that one
that is a historical thing there is a
whole lineage of programming languages
PHP is one Pearl was one
on the unique shell
uh is one of the oldest or or all the
different shells
the dollar was invented for that purpose
because a very earliest shells had a
notion of scripting but they did not
have a notion of parameterizing the
scripting
all right and so a script is just a few
lines of text
where each line of text is a command
that is read by a very primitive command
processor that then sort of takes the
first word on the line as the name of a
program and passes all the all the rest
of the line as text into the program for
the program to figure out what to do
with as arguments
and so by the time scripting was
slightly more mature than the very first
script
there was a convention that just like
the first word of line is uh the name of
the program the following words
uh could be names or files
input.text
output.html things like that
the next thing that happens is oh it
would actually be really nice if we
could have variables and especially
parameters for scripts parameters are
usually what starts this process
but now you have a problem because you
can't just
say the parameters are x y and z
and so now we we call say let's say x is
the input file and Y is the output file
and let's forget about Z for now I have
my program
and I write program X Y well that
already has a meaning because that
presumably means
X itself is the file
it's a file name it's not a variable
name
uh and so
the inventors of of things like the
unique shell and I'm sure job command
language in at IBM before that
uh
how to use
something that made it clear to the
script processor
here is an X that is not actually the
name of a file which you just pass
through to the to the program you're
running here is an X that is the name of
a variable yeah and
when you're writing a script processor
you try to keep it as simple as possible
because at as certainly in the 50s and
60s
uh the thing that interprets the script
was itself a very had to be a very small
program because it had to fit in a very
small part of memory and so saying oh
just look at each character and if you
see a dollar sign you jump to another
section of the code and then you gobble
up characters or say until the next
space or something and you say that's
the variable name
and so it was was sort of
invented as
a clever way to make parsing of things
that contain but contain both variable
and fixed parts
very easy in a very simple script
processor it also helps even then it
also helps the human
author and the human reader of the
the script
to quickly see oh
20 lines down in the script I see a
reference to x y z Oh it has a dollar in
front of it so now we know that x y z
must be one of the parameters of the
script well this is fascinating several
things to say which is
the leftovers from the simple script
processor languages are now in code
bases like behind Facebook or behind
most of the back end I think php's
probably still runs most of the back end
of the internet oh yeah yeah I think
there's a lot of it in Wikipedia too for
example yeah it's funny that those
decisions are not funny it's fascinating
that those decisions permeate Through
Time
just like biological systems right
I mean that the sort of the inner
workings of DNA
have been stable for well I don't know
how long it was like 300 million years
half a billion years yeah and there
there are all sorts of weird quirks
there
that don't make a lot of sense if you
were to design a system like
self-replicating molecules from scratch
well that system has a lot of
interesting resilience it has redundancy
that results like it messes up in
interesting ways that still is resilient
when you look at the system level of the
organism code doesn't necessarily have
that a program a computer programming
code you'd be surprised
how much resilience modern code has
I mean if you if you look at the number
of bugs per line of code
even in in very well tested
code that in practice works just fine
there are actually lots of things that
don't work fine
and there are error correcting or
self-correcting mechanisms at many
levels including probably the user of
the code well in the end the user who
sort of is told well you got to reboot
your your PC is part of that system and
a slightly uh less drastic thing is
reload the page which we all know how to
do without thinking about it when
something weird happens you you try to
reload a few times before you say oh
there's something really weird okay or
try to click the button again if the
first time didn't work
well yeah that that we should all have
learned not to do that because that's
probably just gonna turn the light back
off yeah true so do it three times
that's the that's the right lesson so uh
and I wonder how many people actually
like the dollar sign like you said it is
documentation so to me it's whatever the
opposite of syntactic sugar is syntactic
poison
to me it is such a pain in the ass that
I have to type in a dollar sign also
super error prone so it's not
self-documenting it's it's like a bug
generating thing it is a kind of
documentation that's the pro and the con
is it's a source of a lot of bugs